car les deux monnaies bonjour bonsoir
merci de nous accueillir dans votre
atelier a fait plaisir
vos oeuvres viennent de partir pour
toronto grosse exposition à l'arsenal
vous avez aussi exposés ou et de
limousines
est ce que le witness et un point
tournant dans votre carrière c'est vrai
que c'était une porte d'entrée vers un
plus grand marché où au moins que parce
que les gens en europe
regarde ce qui se fait à bétheny aux
etats-unis aussi donc c'est sûr que j'ai
une plus grande visibilité à cause de
bétheny mon oeuvre qui était présenté
là-bas mauvaise après un voyage est
vraiment beaucoup ça lui a donné comme
un deuxième souffle ans pour l'écrire la
maison plusieurs de vos films se
retrouvent sur internet et je
m'attardais à créature al nahda où vous
êtes entouré de femmes très inspiré oui
j'ai en fait j'ai invité six femmes
autour de ma table six femmes
autochtones francophones qui sont
vraiment des délits dans leur communauté
des femmes fortes dont à l'année ce
baume swing la grande dame du
documentaire au canada et plus plus et
c'est je pense était spécial parce que
c'est très rare qu'on a l'occasion de se
rencontrer et de prendre le temps de
partager à la pomme et de discuter
d'échanger comme ça puis c'était aussi
en réponse toute la polémique des femmes
victimes d'abus à val d'or venait de
sortir dans les médias on en parlait
beaucoup et puis il y avait une certaine
lourdeur attachés à tout ce qu'il y
avait une volonté de montrer la femme
autochtone complètement différemment de
ce qui était montré dans les médias
c'est à dire dans avec une élégance une
beauté une fierté une exubérance même
une excentricité
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai voulu faire
avec créatures d'aden montré la couleur
de la force et la volonté de s'affirmer
de changer les choses
caroline monnaie poursuit celle qui ne
vous connaissent pas la petite histoire
c'est votre père est français
votre mère et anishnabe exactement mais
on peut dire qu en quelque sorte votre
métier votre talent vous le devez à vos
parents parce que eux déménagent et de
maison à maison qu'ils rénovaient et
vous avez observé puis vous avez
peut-être adopter certaines de leurs
pratiques
mais j'ai grandi dans les rénovations un
petit peu mes parents c'était leur
passion de flipper des maisons d'acheter
des chalets de les transformer on a
déménagé quelques fois puis donc quand
je rentrais de l'école je posais de la
laine de verre
avec la rénovation puis j'ai baigné là
dedans je suis confortable là dedans
puis aujourd'hui je trouve ça
intéressant que je travaille les
matériaux de construction c'est comme un
rappel un peu de douche bien puis dans
le milieu dans lequel j'ai baigné c'est
un beau clin d'oeil en fait à eux mais
c'est sûr que je pense c'est grâce à ma
mère surtout parce que ma mère était une
très curieuse de la musique la
littérature du cinéma puis je pense
qu'elle nous a inculqué ça à ma soeur et
moi important au début vous vouliez
devenir journaliste oui ça faisait pas
votre affaire
vous avez décidé de devenir artiste
alors comment s'est fait le déclic pour
soi ben oui j'ai fait des études en
sociologie communication en pensant que
je voulais devenir journaliste ou
documentariste qui vont à winnipeg j'ai
eu l'occasion de travailler dans la
salle de nouvelles de radio-canada là
bas puis je me suis rendu compte que
vraiment c'est être pas le format pour
moi les deux minutes ratées de des
sujets très rapide moi je voulais aller
plus en profondeur je voulais faire de
la recherche je voulais aller à la
rencontre des gens puis c'est comme ça
que j'ai découvert plus le cinéma
expérimental le documentaire c'est un
rythme qui était juste plus approprié
pour moi c'est tout j'ai fait un
milicien
jamin unipec jusqu'à quel point ça a
marqué votre parcours parce que c'est
une ville de tous les possibles en fait
c'est ce que je pense je pense qu'il
aime beaucoup de possibilités pour
grandir à winnipeg en chef et la boj
était vraiment tout jeune je faisais pas
encore d'or et c'est vraiment là bas que
j'ai rencontré des artistes pour la
première fois que j'ai rencontré des
gens qui vivent est ce que je me suis
mis c'est dans une communauté autochtone
ipa biberon tepa urbaine avec m'a
encouragée à poursuivre mes rêves poussé
à juste trouver des façons de m'exprimer
donc ça a été un tournant pour moi la
winnipeg caroline monnaie j'ai vraiment
l'impression que 2021 ça va être votre
année voyons une exposition au musée des
beaux-arts de montréal
vous allez avoir un premier long métrage
comment vous voyez 2021 b c'est sûr que
le sari 21 avec le musée et puis le long
métrage met ses succès des années de
travail derrière c'est juste que ça
porte fruit
cette année l'exposition au musée des
beaux-arts de montréal c'est vraiment
une belle
une belle invitation je suis très très
contente de pouvoir exposer là c'est ma
première exposition sur le solo dans un
musée canadien donc ça représente quand
même quelque chose d'important
puis puis la sortie du long métrage mais
ça fait cinq ans que je travaille dessus
donc
donc on est content pour de pouvoir
finir un projet aussi on toujours fier
quand un projet abouti car les monnaies
quel plaisir merci beaucoup merci